yes in response to escalating violence
in Khartoum and because of a specific
threats and violence directed towards
diplomats in the Khartoum we have taken
the decision to
temporarily close the British Embassy in
Khartoum to evacuate the British
diplomats and their dependents and
relocate our diplomatic functions into a
nearby diplomatic post we continue to
work directly and through our
International Partners to call for a
ceasefire and an end to this violence
the safety and protection of British
Nationals in Sudan remains a priority
for us a top priority for us and we'll
discharge that Duty through our
embassies based in the area in close
coordination with their International
friends and partners friends
fantastic thank you my first question is
of course as you mentioned the UK
government has started evacuating kind
of looking into British diplomats what
about British Nationals who are kind of
Trapped in Sudan is there a plan to get
them out is the UK just going to abandon
them just give me a sense of the kind of
operation that's going on
our duty to British Nationals in Sudan
remains our top priority uh alongside
our International allies and other
members of the International Community
and in response to direct threats
targeting at the Diplomatic community in
Khartoum we have taken the decision to
temporarily close the embassy and to
relocate our Embassy staff that gives us
a the best opportunity to project our
diplomatic support back into Sudan
we have taken advantage of a a temporary
Lull in the uh violence that we're
seeing in Sudan but we remain absolutely
committed to support British Nationals
in Sudan we will do so in close
coordination with Iran's national
Partners but the best thing that we can
do to support British Nationals and
indeed everyone in Sudan
is push the generals involved in this
conflict to bring it to an end and that
will remain the priority of our
diplomatic focus in the region
why is it that the British government is
prioritizing uh diplomats over ordinary
British citizens who may be trapped in
Sudan
well the the diplomats that were working
in the British Embassy in Khartoum have
been unable to discharge their functions
because of the violence in that City so
both to uh fulfill our duty
to protect them as their employer we are
relocating them to other embassies in
the region
um and in order to continue to protect
the British Nationals we will of course
be enhancing our teams in the region
this is following the pattern that we've
seen of our International friends and
colleagues and we will continue on our
diplomatic effort to bring this conflict
to a swift conclusion because until that
happens we are severely limited in our
ability to provide assistance to British
Nationals I would say to British
Nationals in the region please register
with us we have circulated a link so we
know who is there where they are so if
an opportunity arises we can find a way
of helping them great thank you um why
would both the Ambassador and the deputy
Ambassador out of Sudan at the same time
do you think that was a mistake
well diplates move in and out of our
embassies and move internationally as an
inevitable part of their job there were
senior leadership still at the British
Embassy in Khartoum and actually having
The Ambassador in the UK being able to
provide direct
experience and knowledge to our crisis
response Center here in London has
proven to be invaluable so our duty now
is to make sure that we are able to
relocate our diplomatic staff and then
continue to support the British
Nationals who are still currently in
Sudan